all right let's hear from a few more
folks via the david pakman show discord
server which you can find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to trudy from
glasgow trudy you're on the air
hi david how are you i'm very good
thanks how are you
i'm doing well i just wanted to phone up
and
uh thank you very much for the common
sense that you bring to things
my pleasure um it's just very nice to
hear your point of view
obviously living in scotland we're back
in a full lockdown at the moment so
um we're all staying at home i
work at a primary school for five to
twelve year olds so
i'm still at work um but everyone else
is at home
so how are things looking from the
standpoint of vaccination
um at the moment i think in scotland
we're
just sending out letters for the over
60s
to get an appointment for vaccination
that's interesting it's being done by uh
paper letters are being sent out that's
i've not heard of that before
yes yeah you get uh you get an
appointment
um to go to your local vaccination
center
interesting and is that is it going more
slowly than people would like i mean i
guess no matter what it's going more
slowly than people would like
but yeah i mean it's certainly going
more slowly i think than i would like
um but obviously they're they're doing
all they can
or you hope or you presume that they're
doing all they can to get as many people
vaccinated as possible
of course yeah and is there uh how how
strong is
the anti-vaxx movement in scotland
it's not very strong it's not strong
enough that i'm aware of it oh that's
good that's good if you're not aware of
it that's a great start like i'm
very aware of it in the united states
right i mean i know of a few
people who have said oh i'm i'm not sure
if i'm going to get it or not or
um but that really that's just a
personal point of view it's right
it's not really a whole movement have
you um
do you know people who have been
vaccinated and my mom just had her first
dose last week
so oh okay and side effects how were
they
nothing really she felt a little unwell
you know a bit of a headache for a
couple of days but that was all
wow yeah yeah i was down with a fever 36
hours i was shocked truly
wow right okay yeah no she had the the
oxford asked us anyone so
ah okay okay yeah that one is not
currently available in the us but
um very it's great that that there are
so many vaccines now on the precipice of
approval
well good trudy i i appreciate your
comments and hope uh hope
people get vaccinated soon thank you for
your time
my pleasure all right trudy from glasgow
what a polite perfect phone call
unbelievable